-Quickly, today's a little
anniversary for us.
It's been -- 13 years ago,
we started late night.
-13?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
That's a long --
13?
-13 years ago, yeah.
March 2nd, so yeah.
-Now it's a teenager.
-Yeah. Exactly, yeah.
So, 13 years ago,
we actually made --
we made a yearbook.
Because we were so excited just
to be on the air for a year.
We didn't think we'd
go further than a year.
So, we were so excited.
We made a fake yearbook.
"Learning to Fly" is our theme.
What I love -- I was looking
at it today, just going --
2009, the first year,
we dedicated to --
to Wayne Federman, who's
a great comedian, and then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, and then
if you go down here, it's
a rebuttal to the dedication,
'cause he's still alive,
and so we just --
[ Laughter ]
And here's --
This is one thing I kept.
I hang it on my office wall
just to keep me grounded,
'cause you can't get a big head
in this business,
no matter what.
You get so excited.
You go, "Oh, my gosh.
I got late night,
and this is such a big deal."
And, you know,
I got to thank Conan O'Brien
for keeping the show on the air.
He did 16 years.
David Letterman.
-Yep.
-Unbelievable.
I wouldn't have a job
if it wasn't for those guys.
And I was just so excited
I got my thing,
and then I get to my office,
and this is hanging
in front of my office.
Can you see this?
No glare?
They spelled my name wrong.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Jimmy Falon."
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Falon.
"Who's the new guy?"
-Yeah, NBC is like, "Yeah,
you'll get there one day, yeah."
I was like, "Don't take it off.
Don't change that.
I gotta save that," so, anyways,
thanks to everyone
who worked on that show
and everyone for watching us
for all these years.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fun times.
Here we are.